Ist das jetzt einfach ein Winter oder tatsächlich
außergewöhnlich?
Gebäude sind meterhoch eingeschneit, Lawinen
gehen ab und der Verkehr liegt teilweise lahm.
Viele Medien berichten von einer “weißen
Katastrophe” oder “Schnee-Hölle”.
Ist das jetzt tatsächlich der Jahrhundertwinter,
vor dem einige Wetterexperten gewarnt hatten?!
Wie bedrohlich ist die Lage wirklich?
Steht uns allen ein Mega-Winter bevor?!
Das alles erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction, herzlich willkommen?
Anfang des Jahres überschlugen sich die Meldungen:
Ein sogenannter Polarwirbelsplit werde Eis
und Schnee bringen - ein Jahrhundertwinter
sollte demnach im Januar 2019 seinen Anfang
nehmen.
Doch wie kommen Experten und Expertinnen auf
diese Vorhersagen?
Fest steht: Ein Polarwirbelsplit hat tatsächlich
häufig Auswirkungen auf das Wetter in Mitteleuropa.
Über den Polen der Antarktis und Arktis herrschen
großräumige Tiefdrucksysteme und das sind
eben die sogenannten Polarwirbel.
Die Kaltluftzonen drehen sich der Drehrichtung
der Erde entgegengesetzt.
Wenn dann warme Luft aus dem Pazifik oder
vom Atlantik in die Polarregion vordringt,
erwärmt sich die Stratosphäre in einer Höhe
von 10.000 bis 50.000 Metern.
Der Polarwirbel wird dadurch gestört und
geschwächt und es kann zur Teilung in zwei
Wirbel kommen.
Das passiert oft in den Wintermonaten Januar
oder Februar.
Doch solch ein Polarwirbelsplit bedeutet keinesfalls,
dass das Winterwetter in Mitteleuropa zwangsläufig
sehr extrem sein wird.
Denn da spielen weitere Faktoren mit hinein.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Einige Regionen Deutschland
und Österreichs sind ordentlich eingeschneit.
In einigen Orten bleiben die Schulen geschlossen
und der Bahnverkehr liegt lahm.
Einige Wetterexperten und expertinnen gehen
davon aus, dass diese Wetterlage noch eine
längere Zeit andauern könnte.
Der Grund: Der Polarwirbel sei Anfang Januar
in zwei Teile zerbrochen und vom Nordpol abgedrängt
worden.
Luftströmungen in der Arktis und im Nordatlantik
würden dadurch gestört.
Die Folgen: Kalte Luftmassen der Arktis setzen
sich in Bewegung - und zwar Richtung Mitteleuropa.
Manche Meteorologen sind der Ansicht, dass
dies Ende Januar für eine Mega-Kälte mit
Tiefstwerten von minus 20 Grad sorgen könnte.
Möglich sei dann auch, dass dies den Winter
um Wochen verlängert und die Kälte noch
bis in den März andauern könnte.
Doch es gibt auch andere Modelle, und die
sagen - wie so oft beim Wetter - etwas völlig
anderes voraus: einen eher milden Winter nämlich.
Festhalten kann man jedenfalls: Eine solche
Wetterlage wie derzeit gibt es nicht jedes
Jahr.
Aber so katastrophal, wie sie in manchen Medien
dargestellt wird, ist sie auch nicht.
Klar, es ist Winter und diesmal in Österreich
und Bayern auch so richtig.
Und bei Schnee und Eis muss man vorsichtig
sein: Bei höchster Lawinenwarnstufe sollte
man nicht die Pisten verlassen.
Doch die Einheimischen bleiben gelassen.
Denn Schnee in den Alpen ist nichts Ungewöhnliches.
Das zeigt sich beispielsweise auch in den
österreichischen Medien, die von der alarmierenden
Berichterstattung der Deutschen genervt sind.
Der salzburgische Tourismusverband Filzmoos
schreibt am 10.1. bei Facebook: “Leider
wird die aktuelle Wetterlage in den Medien
sehr übertrieben.
Die Einwohner von Filzmoos sind große Schneemassen
gewohnt und wissen mit der Situation umzugehen.
Im Ort droht keine Lawinengefahr - betroffene
Straßen wurden aus Vorsichtsmaßnahmen gesperrt,
damit keine Personen in diese Bereiche kommen.
Bitte lasst euch nicht durch Medienberichte
verunsichern.”
Von einer Winter-Katastrophe wie beispielsweise
1978/1979 sind wir jedenfalls noch weit entfernt.
Das war wirklich krass: Am 28.12.1978 beispielsweise
zeigte das Thermometer morgens vielerorts
noch um die 10 Grad plus an, nachmittags stürzten
die Werte dann um bis zu 30 Grad Celsius.
Hinzu kamen Schnee und ein schwerer Sturm.
Der Norden von Deutschland versank im Schnee.
Der Katastrophenalarm wurde ausgerufen und
die Menschen erlebten tatsächlich eine Art
Jahrhundertwinter.
Also erstmal Entwarnung.
Füsse still halten.
Alles ganz entspannt.
Das muss man übrigens auch sein, wenn man
sich selbst lebendig mumifiziert.
What?
Das geht?
Neugierzone erklärt es hier.
Einfach drauf klicken.
Bis dann bleibt dran!